[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
any day now joe biden will announce his
pick for the
actual democratic nominee that's the
person who will run the government if
biden wins in november we've been
telling you about this process for weeks
now
we've taken a closer look at three
potential candidates all of them are
said to be on joe biden's shortlist for
the job
they are stacy abrams karen bass and
kamala harris
now in a normal year no mainstream
candidate would consider
any of these people all of them would be
disqualified without debate
karen bass is a lunatic fidel castro
acolyte
who praised scientology and once
belonged to an armed revolutionary group
she's out stacey abrams is so delusional
she thinks she's the governor of georgia
and by the way she's essentially
unemployed
in one of her last regular jobs she
wrote bad porn novels
for real kamala harris meanwhile is so
transparently transactional that even
democratic
primary voters who have a strong stomach
found her repulsive
pretty much no one who knows kamala
harris likes her
so overall it's not a blue ribbon group
but according to joe biden
this isn't a normal year and the normal
standards don't apply
for what could very well be the most
important job on earth
biden has decided to hire exclusively on
the basis of qualities that are both
immutable and completely irrelevant
race and gender and that's it
but wait a second you ask isn't that
insulting isn't it wrong isn't it
probably illegal
yes it is all three of those things but
no one's pushing back against it so
biden is doing it
the problem is that all three of the
people we just told you about
might wind up in the end hurting the
biden campaign they're just too
unimpressive to run
biden's handlers seem to have figured
this out above
all the democratic party wants to win
this year they're not
in it for sentimental reasons or for
love of joe biden
they're in it for the power and they
want it badly
so today the odds seem to shift
dramatically in another direction
away from karen bass and kamala harris
and stacy abrams
and towards someone you have seen before
that would be former national security
adviser susan rice
as of right now susan rice appears to be
in the lead
for the vp slot that's an interesting
development
say what you will about susan rice and
we're about to
but she is not a buffoon susan rice is
smart she is hard-eyed
she is experienced susan rice knows
exactly
what she wants and she understands the
system well enough to get it
she is a threat so what exactly does
susan rice believe
well in a sentence susan rice believes
what everyone else in permanent
washington believes
because above all rice is a product of
dc
she grew up there so to our political
class rice is the opposite of an
outsider she's the home team
like almost everyone in washington she
is above all a fervent
neocon as a member of obama's cabinet
she pushed for the counterproductive
killing of muammar qaddafi in libya
she has never apologized for that she
should then in the clinton
administration she supported the
bombing of a pharmaceutical factory in
sudan
and needless to say it goes without
saying really rice led the chorus of
liars who claim that donald trump was
secretly
a russian agent he's taken a series of
steps
that had vladimir putin dictated him he
couldn't have mirrored more effectively
what his motivations are i think is a
legitimate question
one that i trust that the special
counsel
is investigating but the policies that
this president has pursued globally
have served vladimir putin's interest in
dividing the west
undermining democracy does that mean you
think it's an open question whether or
not he's compromised by russia
george i don't know what his motivations
are i think that's a legitimate question
now to be perfectly clear this is not
someone who's just throwing words out
this is someone who's highly
sophisticated in the nuances
of foreign policy in other words susan
rice knew perfectly well when she said
what you just heard
that it was false she knew that much of
this administration's
actual agenda from arming ukraine to
expanding domestic energy production
here in the u.s
hurt russian interests badly
and yet rice didn't acknowledge that
instead she smeared the president as a
kremlin
pawn in fact what rice objected to
were trump's foreign policy views views
which not incidentally the majority of
americans say they support
it turns out that only people in
washington like susan rice
want more pointless wars around the
world because they're the ones who
profit from them
most normal people don't want more
pointless wars because they're the ones
who fight them
but rice doesn't care either way watch
your reaction to the administration's
plan to remove
troops from syria i woke up this morning
to hear that news and as i do
it seems like six days a week i just put
my head in my hands
this is back crazy
oh yeah it's crazy it's almost
unbelievable
it's crazy to bring troops home
from a country that we have no strategic
interest
in who are there to fulfill a mission we
can't articulate that's crazy
but that's a consensus view in
washington when the us consulate in
benghazi was destroyed in 2012 rice
herself said something that was
actually crazy she blamed that attack on
an
online video once again rice knew when
she said it
it wasn't true but she said it anyway
what sparked the recent violence was the
airing on the internet of a
very hateful very offensive video it
began
spontaneously in benghazi as a
reaction to what had transpired some
hours earlier
in cairo where of course as you know
there was a
violent protest outside of our embassy
sparked by this
hateful video what happened in benghazi
was in fact
initially a spontaneous uh reaction to
what had just transpired
hours before in cairo what happened this
week
in cairo uh in in benghazi
and in many other parts of the region
tunisia
a cartoon result of a heinous and
offensive video
it was heinous it was offensive it was
hateful
this video which dared criticize radical
islam people saw this they were so
offended that they justifiably rose up
and started shooting americans that was
the implication of what she said
but rice knew that was a lie when she
said it
she knew the attack in benghazi was not
spontaneous
it wasn't based in outrage and it was
not staged in response
to that or any other video she knew that
because her own intelligence reports
made it perfectly clear but it was an
election year
and rice said what she had to say by the
way the man who actually made the video
the heinous offensive hateful video
was a coptic christian he was arrested
after rice's appearances on television
he was jailed without bail
it was a purely political prosecution of
the kind the rest of us reassure
ourselves doesn't happen in this country
but unfortunately sometimes does
whatever happened to that man no one
checked we did today
four years later he was living in a
homeless shelter his life was completely
destroyed
susan rice has never apologized to him
doesn't appear to have even looked back
that's a moral crime has rice committed
legal crimes
u.s attorney john durham is looking into
that right now and of course we'll bring
you the results of that investigation
when they finally appear we're still
waiting we do know
though that rice monitored conversations
that trump advisors were having with
foreign officials
and then requested the unmasking of
those advisors rice was asked about this
in a television interview
and here's how she responded during the
transition
after uh president trump uh had been
elected
that he and the people around him may
have been caught up in surveillance
of foreign individuals and that their
identities
may have been disclosed do you know
anything about this i know nothing about
this
i was surprised to see reports from
chairman eunice on that count today
here's just a pro tip in case you're
watching these interviews at home
when a political figure laughs in a way
that suggests not real mirth but
nervousness in the middle of an answer
that's a tell that means they're lying
and in fact she was lying in that
interview we know that for certain
the other thing we know for certain is
that susan rice will say whatever she
thinks it takes
so it's not surprising that joe biden is
considering her tonight and once again
he definitely is